[Music]
billy eilish stuns with her performance
of no time to die at the academy awards
[Music]
[Music]
with her brother phineas at the piano
billy sings the title song for daniel
craig's final outing as double of seven
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's just no time to die
bond has meant so much to us for so long
that like we needed to live up to it or
else that's billy and phineas chatting
with e.t before the performance
was nervous
not sucking
i mean that's kind of my mindset doing
anything but especially at the oscars
um yeah i think i'm gonna just try not
to suck and like be the best that i can
and i'm i'm really excited this is a
song that i genuinely
like adore to be honest and i don't know
if that's cocky but i love i love this
song we created i feel really proud of
it and
i love to perform it so i'm excited
after the performance billy and phineas
later nabbed the oscar for best original
song
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys oh my gosh um this is so
wonderful people can scream the road to
the oscars was a long one the pair wrote
the song over three years ago and it
debuted in early 2020 leading up to no
time to die's original release date but
amid the coronavirus pandemic the movie
didn't hit theaters until october
we all have our secrets
we just didn't get to yours yet
in the meantime billy and phineas
actually won a grammy for the song
before the movie had actually come out
we should also note this means the
brother sister duo are halfway to
landing the egot we've looked up to
the music in the bond franchise for
pretty much like as long as i can
remember speaking backstage they
reflected on their unique journey to the
oscars there was um
no uh confusion at all about bond and
the music it has been such a big part of
our lives for so long that the fact that
we are involved at all was
unbelievable
and the approach was very
very exhilarating it was really
important to us that it felt like a
billy island song and a james bond song
at the same time and not one or the
other we just wanted it to be perfect
and represent daniel craig's last film
and all of his films and how much you
know he put into it and
it just was the most amazing experience
ever
[Music]
you